[موسيقى]
قد ما ذكرت لي الفحو الطلب
سالتها قلت لها هذا يعني رساله من
البنتاغون من اي جهه قالت لي من كل الجهات
يعني من البنتاجون من
بيت الابيض من كل المتفقين اصحاب القرار
متفقين على رساله يكتب خطيده تطلع انت
بالاعلام تقراها مقابل هذا طبعا يطلب من
القوات
نعم نعم
مقابل هذا يخرج الى احد ثلاث عواصم عربيه
اخترناها واتفقنا معه هي هذه العواصم
الاردن مصر دول نعم نعم مصر قطر
[موسيقى]
عرضوا عليك عرض شخصي لالك نعم وايضا اني
اذا اقنعته
[موسيقى]
ممكن يعني اكون معها يعني اخرج انا
وعائلتي
وجيبي متصل مثل ما يعني حكوا جيب متصل وما
عندي مشكله واي واحد يريده
اي واحد يقدر الرئيس يخرج معه يخرج لكن
يعتزل عمل سياسي بشكل نهائي والعمل
الاعلامي
اكدت مره ثانيه
ولرئيس ولمن يخرج معي الرئيس
[موسيقى]